was shot when she was entering her home
in Port-au-Prince
she had just arrived from work when a
stray bullet hit her back
that was two months ago but the bullet
has not been removed because she was
told at the hospital there were no
doctors available to remove it she's um
I was here talking to my neighbor and I
felt something hit me in the back I
heard the kids scream mum got shot I
still have the bullet in my back the
situation now each day is very bad we
cannot live in peace
Hades and Chaos caught in battles
between rival gangs
barricades like this one are being set
up all around port or Prince and people
are using them not only to prevent their
neighborhoods from being attacked by
gangs but also to prevent gangs from
moving freely this road connects the
community with another area that is not
far away and we're told that it was
being used by gangs to move people that
had been kidnapped
is a political activist he says the
government is not doing enough to fight
the gangs and that's why he's protecting
his neighborhood
it costs so much money for regular
Haitian to get anything out of Customs
but every day guns are coming through
our customs there are more than a
million guns and the closest port is in
Florida
tired Haitians have started to go after
the gangs themselves and have killed and
set on fire dozens of suspected gang
members
a political crisis is complicating the
situation in Haiti even more Ariel
Enrique became the interim prime
minister when President jovenel mois was
assassinated in 2021
but he was not ratified in Congress the
last national elections happened in
2016.
[Music]
members of the opposition formed what is
known as the Montana Accord to create a
transitional government but they have
failed to convince the government to
step down
there's a Nexus between the political
Elite and the Coalition of political or
criminal groups in the country so if we
don't break this Nexus between the
political and economic Elite and this
Coalition of of criminal groups there's
no way we can talk about security
the ongoing statement is prolonging the
suffering of the Haitian people
caught between the gang Warfare and the
government's inability to end it
Prince
okay lots more